a new ore lighter than silk harder than
iron as Weaponry it would best the
dwarf's proudest blades what is Duran
talking about find out about the origin
story Tolkien never envisioned season
one of the Lord of the Rings the rings
of power has set out to expand J.R.R
tolkien's lore rather than adapted beat
for Beat of course this was always
inevitable as the Amazon series takes
place during the second age of Middle
Earth which isn't covered in great
detail in the author's writings so the
show's writers have been tasked with
filling in the blanks in an attempt to
create a fully realized universe that
complements the Lord of the Rings books
and movies as such the rings of power
has also been an Unexpected Journey at
times the show's creators have
introduced some of their own ideas into
the proceedings as well some of which
cannot be found in any previous Lord of
the Rings story for example Adder will
upset Tolkien purists as he's a brand
new character who was created for the
Amazon series furthermore he's nothing
like the elves in Tolkien stories though
his existence indicates that rings of
power fans can look forward to a few
surprises the fifth installment of the
Rings of power picks up the pace and
continues that trend of adding fresh
elements into the mix including one new
origin story that doesn't exist in
tolkien's writings before we get into
how the rings of power reimagines the
origins of mithril let's discuss its
history and tolkien's stories the Lord
of the Rings books describes me thrill
as a silvery medal that was primarily
found in the minds of Moria the material
is both lightweight and strong which
makes it ideal for creating battle armor
however it also boasts a shiny glow that
makes it perfect for creating beautiful
jewelry meaning that it was Often craved
by those who enjoy the Finer Things in
life mithril is viewed as a source of
wealth and power in Middle Earth having
been worn by some of its most notable
figures for example galadriel's ring
nenya was made of mithril and that's one
of the three rings of power that was
given to the elves expect that ring
Defector into the rings of power
sometime in the future of course any
treasure that's so widely craved brings
out the worst in people mithril was the
main source of the door warp's wealth
before their kingdom was overtaken by
the balrog basically the dwarves became
greedy and craved more me thrill causing
them to dig deep into the mines and
disrupt the fiery demon that dwelled in
the shadows naturally the demon wasn't
willing to share it with anyone who
entered the mines afterward episode 5 of
the Rings of power sees gilgalad
provides some fresh insight into the
history of mithril the elf connects it
to the silmarils which are gems forged
by the elf feyenoor from the Trees of
valinor during the episode gilgalad
tells elrond about a legend pertaining
to a pure-hearted Elven Warrior who got
into a scuffle with the balrog over a
tree in the Misty Mountains the elf
poured all of his good into the tree to
protect it the balrog meanwhile tried to
destroy the tree and instilled it with
his evil Powers their combined might
caused lightning to strike and their
powers combined to create mithril
according to gilgalad the medal is quote
as pure and light as good as strong and
unyielding as evil me thrill will now
play an important role in the rings of
power as gilgolad believes that it's
needed by Spring to prevent the elves
from experiencing a blight in Middle
Earth as such elrond must convince Duran
to give the elves some me thrill and
save the day Tolkien didn't associate me
thrill with the silmarils nor did he
have the elves require the light to stay
fresh so we can shock this backstory up
as another example of the Rings of power
being unpredictable
[Music]